The Disney Princess team-up in the Wreck-It
Ralph sequel almost broke the internet when
the scene was teased in a trailer.
And, having watched the movie, I can confirm
that seeing the iconic princesses assemble
for the first time will not disappoint fans!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here
and today I'm revealing every amazing Disney
princess detail, secret and easter egg you
need to look out for in Ralph Breaks The Internet.
Plus keep watching to the end where I'll reveal
some bonus Frozen easter eggs in the movie.
And to celebrate the the new film, I'm giving
away some awesome Funko Pops.
Hit the bell and make sure you're a subscriber
and leave a comment about the movie to enter.
A really fun moment in Wreck-It Ralph 2 is
when the princesses are so fascinated with
Vanellope's casual clothes that they want
their own.
So, Cinderella has her mice make brand new
outfits for everyone.
And after a 1960s Batman-style transition,
we see the princesses in their new comfy clothing
and Cinderella sighs, 'ah, so this is love'.
Cinders' words poke fun at the song she sings
when she dances with Prince Charming at the
ball and also mock the Disney princess cliché
of true love.
While each piece of the princesses' new clothing
matches the colour scheme of their iconic
outfits, what's especially interesting is
that they're also loaded with easter eggs
and inside jokes.
The tank top Rapunzel wears under her hoodie
has a design which reads "We gotta dream,
the Snuggly Ducklings", a clever call-back
to the song in Tangled "I've Got A Dream"
which Rapunzel sang with the regulars at the
rowdy pub "The Snuggly Duckling".
Her leggings also have a pattern with the
sun crest symbol of Rapunzel's kingdom of
Corona.
For Ariel, the words "gizmos", "whozits",
and "whatzits" appear on her top referring
to the lyrics of her iconic song "Part of
Your World".
And in keeping with Ariel's love of all things
human, she's so amazed at her new "thingamabob",
aka shirt, that she even launches in to song,
singing "I once had a dream that I might wear
a shirt".
Pocahontas's sweater has a design of a wolf
howling at the moon plus the words "Blue Corn
Moon" in a nod to that same line in her song
"Colors of the Wind".
Cinderella's jumper has an image of her classic
pumpkin carriage plus "G2G", aka "Got To Go",
a fun throwback to how she had to leave the
ball before midnight.
And, look at the bean bag she's sitting on,
it's patterned with sparkles like the ones
from the Fairy Godmother's magic wand during
Cinderella's transformation scene.
Belle has a silhouette in the shape of the
Beast on her shirt with the letters "BFF"
which, in this case, are short for "Beast
Friends Forever".
Anna's shirt has a "we finish each other's
sandwiches" theme in a shout-out to her song
with Hans, "Love Is An Open Door".
And Elsa has a blue and white coloured "Just
Let It Go" sweater referencing her iconic
song.
The "NOLA" on Tiana's top is short for "New
Orleans, Louisiana" where she's from and the
crown in the middle of the "O" reflects the
design of The Princess and the Frog's title
card and is also a hat-tip to Prince Naveen.
Moana has hashtag "Shiny" on her shirt together
with a picture of Tamatoa, the villainous
giant crab who sang the memorable song "Shiny"
in her movie.
Mulan wears a bomber jacket that sports some
Mushu artwork on the front and back in honour
of her dragon companion and friend.
Snow White gets a poison apple-themed top,
Jasmine has the genie's three wishes, and
Sleeping Beauty's top appropriately points
out that she's the "Nap Queen".
Merida's shirt has a bear and the word "mum"
on the front because her mother [Queen Elinor]
transformed into a bear after eating enchanted
cake.
There are also tons of amazing background
details and easter eggs for fans to uncover
in the scene, especially on the princesses'
individual dressing tables.
For example, Belle often switches back to
reading during the scene and so, of course,
there's a stack of books in her cubicle.
Just in front of the books on the table, is
the magic mirror from Beauty and the Beast,
and a candelabra, which is a hat-tip to Lumiere.
In Ariel's cubicle, there's a reminder of
her fascination with human objects because
if you look very carefully, you'll spot a
box of thingamabobs.
And you can also see the candelabra from her
secret grotto.
On Tiana's mirror, there's a picture of "Tiana's
Place", the restaurant she and her father
dreamed of opening and which became a reality
for her in The Princess And The Frog, and
on the table, there's a plate of her famous
"man-catching" beignets.
Also in the background is a photograph of
young Tiana with her parents.
Continuing the bear theme of Merida's clothes,
she has several toy bears on her vanity table.
On top of Anna's dressing table, you can see
a vase of sunflowers, which reflects just
how much she loves those flowers as we've
seen throughout the Frozen films.
And you can also just about make out the dolls
of the sisters which appeared during the "Do
You Wanna Build A Snowman?"
song in the first Frozen movie.
In Rapunzel's area, you can see her chameleon
Pascal sitting on top of her paint box, and
there's a painting of an owl, which is a shout-out
to the owl belonging to her friend and handmaiden
Cassandra in the Tangled TV series.
Cinderella has a pumpkin on her dresser as
well as a clock that's stuck at midnight and
Jasmine, of course, has Aladdin's magic carpet
and the genie's lamp.
The crests above each dressing area are also
suitable symbols for each princess.
For Ariel, there's a nautilus shell referencing
Ursula's enchanted necklace which held Ariel's
voice that she gave to the sea witch in exchange
for human legs.
Tiana has a water lily, Rapunzel has the magical
golden flower, the Frozen sisters have a crocus
reminiscent of the official crest of Arendelle,
and Cinderella has a glass slipper.
There are also some clever little tributes
and easter eggs to signature details we associate
with the princesses.
As Vanellope glitches into the room, Aurora
is asleep on a chaise longue holding a red
rose and in exactly the same pose she was
during her enchanted slumber in her original
1959 movie.
Rapunzel continues to indulge her love of
painting as you can spot her here very briefly
painting on the side walls of her dressing
area!
And while the other princesses lounge around
on chairs, bean bags or cushions, Rapunzel
actually sits in a chair of her own hair!
Another detail you'll need to look carefully
for is Cinderella plucking a leaf out of Pocahontas's
hair.
That moment is a little homage to the leaves
we see swirling around Pocahontas during her
song "Colors of the Wind".
And in another nod to that song, watch how
Pocahontas's hair is constantly in motion
with magical wind blowing through her tresses
even though she's indoors.
And when the princesses spring into action
they brandish many of their signature weapons
or items, with Cinderella going hilariously
dark and smashing her glass slipper making
it into a shiv.
You'll have doubtless noticed Merida's bow,
Mulan's sword, Belle's book and Rapunzel's
frying pan, but a little harder to spot is
Ariel brandishing her dinglehopper.
"What is it?"
"It's a dinglehopper."
Also in this shot, Elsa stands ready to ice
Vanellope with her freezing powers.
Elsa's sister Anna doesn't have a weapon,
but she does have her fists at the ready,
which is a nice call-back to that moment in
Frozen where she punched the villainous Hans
in the face.
Moana has the oar we've seen her use to threaten
Maui.
Tiana, being the gifted cook she is, has a
rolling pin.
And Sleeping Beauty has a spindle from her
spinning wheel.
Pocahontas wields the club that her father
was going to use to execute John Smith.
And Jasmine brandishes the Genie's lamp.
There's also a cameo appearance by Pocahontas's
raccoon Meeko although he's clearly not a
fan of Vanellope when she goes to pet him;
and we also see Cinderella with her mice and
birds, and Jasmine with her pet tiger Rahjah.
There's another funny nod to Aurora's sleepiness
when she starts to doze off while Merida's
talking.
Merida wakes her up with a jolt and the look
on Aurora's face is just priceless.
Near the start of the scene, after Pocahontas
asks Vanellope what type of princess she is,
the other princesses humorously run through
a list of tropes that have been part of their
characters over the years.
"Do you have magic hair?"
"No."
"Magic hands?"
"Do animals talk to you?"
"No."
"Were you poisoned?"
"Cursed, kidnapped or enslaved?"
"No!
Are you guys OK?
Shall I call the police?"
"Then I have to assume you made a deal with
an underwater sea witch where she took your
voice in exchange for a pair of human legs!"
"No.
Good lord!
Who would do that?!"
"Have you ever had true love's kiss?"
"Eugh!
Barf!"
"Do you have daddy issues?"
"I don't even have a mom."
"Neither do we!"
That last joke is a reference to the dark
truth that so many Disney princesses don't
actually have a mother who's still alive.
Which is possibly due to the fact that Walt
Disney felt responsible for the death of his
own mother, so the theory is the studio adopted
a kind of "no mothers" policy in the stories
they developed.
Now, if the princess scenes in Ralph Breaks
The Internet impressed you with how true they
felt to the original characters, that's in
part because most of the original actors who
voiced the characters returned to record lines
for the new movie.
In fact, when each actress came in to the
studio to record her lines, she would often
make some little tweaks and changes to make
the script feel slightly more authentic to
each princess.
Of course, some of the original actresses
weren't available.
Adriana Caselotti, who voiced Snow White,
and Ilene Woods, who voiced Cinderella, are
sadly no longer with us and Mary Costa, the
original voice of Aurora, is retired.
However, Jennifer Hale and Kate Higgins provided
voices for Cinderella and Aurora respectively
as they have voiced those characters in recent
Disney projects.
And lending her voice to Snow White was Ralph
Breaks The Internet co-writer Pamela Ribon.
There are also some other great Disney princess
easter eggs peppered throughout the film.
During the pancake-milkshake game, the little
toddler watching looks incredibly like baby
Moana.
It seems a deliberate choice by the filmmakers
as the little girl's official name has been
revealed as "Mo".
On top of that, there's an even sneakier easter
egg in this scene because Mo's mother, who's
driving the car, is actually voiced by Nicole
Scherzinger, who also voiced Moana's mother
in the 2016 animated movie.
I also noticed several other Frozen easter
eggs outside the main princess scenes in Ralph
Breaks The Internet.
When Vanellope arrives at Oh My Disney, listen
out for the pop version of Frozen's "Let It
Go".
And among the viral cat videos that Ralph
and Vanellope encounter is one of a grumpy-looking
cat pushing a little Anna doll off a table.
Also, the Frozen sisters' father King Agnarr
appears in a pop-up ad!
Finally, there's an amazing additional scene
with the princesses late on in Ralph Breaks
The Internet, however, I don't want to spoil
it here so I may do a separate video about
that.
Now, who's your favourite Disney princess
in the movie?
And would you like to see any of the princesses
team up for their own film?
Don't forget to comment and subscribe for
a chance to win a Funko Pop.
Tap left for my next Wreck-It Ralph video
or tap right for another video you're sure
to like!
And if you enjoyed this, remember to share
and leave a thumbs-up for more videos like
this.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!